on poursuit ce soir la tournée de notre
collègue émilie dubreuil qui sonde
l'humeur des électeurs un peu partout
dans la grande région ce soir 01/12
amène à l'encan agricole de
saint-hyacinthe où vous allez voir il ya
des électeurs qui se sentent totalement
oublié par la campagne
c'est ça l'enjeu est aujourd'hui de
l'agneau de l'agneau de la brebis de
réformes
déjà en belgique en agriculture on n'a
plus beaucoup d'elle c'est très dur très
très ému il ya aucun jeune qui peut
repartir très dur de s'enfuir pris 48
le matériel animaux il n'y a plus de
relais d'abord tu vois partout dans les
fermes c'est une personne de 50 60 ans
les jeunes il a trés faut boire en
agriculture les villages et plus
personne
l'aja ne devenir qu'une médian qu'au
moins de fonds
et de s'envoyer bois
fois qu'ils se réveillent ne sont
peut-être trop tard
mais laurent desbiens on a plus de
20% cette année
nom
et prénom tout le monde s'emballe
respect financer un mac
son combat intéresse maintenant nom de
tous et jonathan leur place toute la
semaine et mon toit commun qui vise la
marque
avec moi c'est des bons temps oui
toujours cash est le meilleur montage
prochain vous allez faire
terry
est ce que vous trouvez pas assez de
latitude
dans la campagne hectares